[Music]
I'm an only child
I had a great childhood I have two
amazing parents that gave me everything
I needed
thought I could fly when I was young
I mean we were poor but
it was so much love that we didn't
really notice
we grew up at an environment where you
never really knew what was going to harm
and
that creates a lot of uncertainty
head to previous generations okay it
might be a bit skinned we might not be
able to afford the best pair of shoes
but we're not living in poverty
we make plenty of money like we make
plenty of money it's not like we won the
lottery and moved into a big fancy
neighborhood
[Music]
my integrity
is what I have you know a long time ago
people's word and integrity meant a lot
[Music]
I grew up happy
in the Appalachian Mountains
we had good Christmases we had love I
was normal
but now
what the hell am I now
[Music]
can you hear me
oh
no challenge is more urgent
we can either settle for a country where
a shrinking number of people do really
well while a growing number barely get
by
or we can restore an economy where
everyone gets a fair shot and everyone
does their fair share and everyone plays
by the same set of rules foreign
states are confronted with an economic
Affliction of great proportions
it is time to reawaken this industrial
giant to get government back within its
means and to lighten our punitive tax
burden on these principles there will be
no compromise
[Applause]
are you going back to work or not
all-out war by the council workers
another industrial dispute this time the
Lorry drivers has led to some Panic
buying in the shops and markets it felt
that whatever the Government tried to do
it wasn't necessarily making things
better it might be making things worse I
did think that the free market would
produce the resources that could make
everybody better off the argument was
that if you did these things we will get
rid of unemployment there'll be more
investment there'll be more income that
will trickle down
for a hundred thousand time water
without big Rewards
people like me are not going to work
15 to 20 hours a day in order to get
rich
[Music]
this is bad
in graduate school my doctoral years I
was told psychologists five to ten years
into practicing on average were making a
hundred thousand dollars a year and I
was like
that sounds awful
that was like kind of like my incentive
to be like the top one percent
I'm not in the top one percent in terms
of the world it's maybe in just the
psychology world
I choose this I choose to drive I could
take a training directly into the city I
just feel like that's one extra time
that I could get sick being in an
enclosed area with lots of strange you
know in the public it's like I don't I
can't afford to be sick at this point in
my career I every day counts while I'm
trying to save for this house
10 minutes to make it to work with
coffee in hand
get my coffee with espresso shot in it
my red eye
and I walked directly to my office
usually here five minutes to 11.
and turn on the lights here sit down and
I go bang bang bang one session after
the next it's non-stop it's not like I
leave I can't leave this little box of
an office I don't have anyone to talk to
like I never need to leave the building
other than to get lunch which I pray to
do every once in a while to get to sit
alone at a counter at a diner across the
street and that to me reading the New
York Post is heaven
[Music]
this morning
we rolling again to the chicken we know
[Music]
there you go
my day starts on Sunday
and doesn't end until the following
Friday
because once Monday here I'm up Eddie
Eddie just like this
it's a constant battle everything
creates a little bit of stress
imma tell y'all one more time
don't come in that deal no more
shut it down
when I get in real
stress mode I might smoke about four or
five cigarettes I don't know
but
you can't drink on your job
because if that was the case I'd have a
flask at work we have potato wedges or
green beans or sweet loose corn or
macaroni and cheese
um
loose corn
macaroni and cheese potato wedges or
green beans okay now what I've done is
mashed potatoes look can you make up
your mind what you want and help you you
know I'm on this end now help me please
we're doing okay
okay I know a little slight
interruptions I know y'all bleep them
out if you can
in Sunderland over one in four men are
unemployed the further 600 backings were
announced last week
started widening rapidly from the mid
80s onwards the weaker trade unions are
the more inequality there is it's a very
striking relationship today's unemployed
are the victims of yesterday's mistakes
but that's the past the government's
getting inflation down interest rates
down reforming Trade union law cutting
regulations and moving restrictions
the balance of power between employers
and employees shifted in favor of
employers I think that happened and I
think it was a deliberate result of
policy
thank you
[Music]
lost
when I go to work in the morning then
you'll probably be in bed when I come in
from work at night and if he's not I'll
not be if he's up I'll be going straight
to bed anyway
[Music]
oh it's a team for the kids
they might still be in bed when I go to
work and then when I come home the back
to bed and I know it just bores the life
of them because they can't do much
[Music]
foreign
zero hours of just the way it works I
just don't know what might happen from
week to week day to day piranha Pirates
John don't eat it just yet like cool
down that slowly thank you you're right
there and we have to top it
somebody dies or somebody goes into
Hospital
it's awful but you think to yourself
because
you're going to lose a lot of hours if
if you don't get something to fill that
Gap anything else I can do very well I'm
here no that's fine thank you again
will she tomorrow yeah I'm probably
going to be a bit late tomorrow I mean
it's Saturday
do we serves as a commissioned out
people are seen as units for sale sold
to the lowest bidder half an hour to get
somebody up get them washed get them
dressed give them the meds and have a
meaningful conversation it doesn't work
how long have you got for this one I'm
gonna be 20 20 25 minutes in here
people look on your own is that all you
do no no it's not all I do I'm not just
a carer I'm a carer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
why don't you let me be
Hind
you keep on holding me
we had went to where my husband was from
and we had decided we were
you know we're gonna um
have our you know have our own business
and everything and that was you know
where we started we had we had a so we
bought a video store and when Walmart
got in the video business it really just
killed it for the mom and pop stores you
know we didn't have the volume of uh
what Walmart would have so
um after five years we ended up closing
it
thank you
I was in the Walmart one day and they
had a son
um they were hiring and I thought well
you know go put an application in and
when they called I was really surprised
and I was even more surprised how good
of a company it was to work for any
extra effort you put forth they
appreciated it the managers would just
come and say I saw what you did and hey
that you know thank you until the
changes came
the focus of the company went to cutting
operational expenses
less people to do the work but yet the
same amount of work we have to go to
work soon
oh two o'clock and I think I go at four
today
3 30 today's the fourth you see you see
every day you're like what time do I go
to work don't you think that is just
nerve-racking
who knows
and I'm not the only one I've talked to
people across the country and they do
the same thing you know it's like what
time do I go to work
you would not believe how much stress
that puts in your life
[Music]
we are living through a moment of
absolutely astonishing transformation
all of you know that the information and
Technology explosion will offer to you
and to the young people of the future
more opportunities and challenges than
any generations of Americans has ever
seen
[Music]
Market boom not seen since the heady
years of the 1980s
the Dow Jones index upped by almost a
quarter in just 12 months with record
profits and million dollar bonuses
appearing in paychecks once again
what's really changed is that if you
were once the CEO of a company your
company served a local market now most
markets that are important are Global in
scope if you're the CEO of Apple
computer and you make the company three
percent more efficient than it would
have been you've added 1.2 billion
dollars to the company's bottom line
your economic value has just grown
explosively we're really pleased to
report that this quarter we earned 106
million dollars
Bill Gates of Microsoft is now worth 29
billion dollars up 10 billion got more
of Intel computers 6.7 billion Up 3
billion and Bill Hewlett of
Hewlett-Packard a personal Fortune of 4
billion up a billion all in just six
months if you end up at the top of this
process then you do have a justification
for what's happening to you the market
is an efficient way of allocating
resources it's allocated a lot of
resources to me and that me must be an
efficient result it must show that I'm
hardworking and clever and in quotes
deserve what I'm getting
very few people have
the mental resources
the energy
I mean look look at me here I am I'm
creating an African art collection I'm
creating companies
my youngest child is three I'm 70 years
old
I have four children 13 and below
so what does that say about me I mean
I'm out there creating
there are a lot of things that
perpetuate inequality economic systems
governments policy one of the things I
would argue is also psychology how
people think the kinds of things that
they value inequality is rising but
people aren't aware of what they're
doing to contribute to that
[Music]
most of the gated communities are either
on a golf course or our Golf Course
adjacent
some of the amenities are really
great really great
but for some people it really it is
about living behind a gate well I live
behind a gate and you do not live behind
a gate and look at how much better it is
that I live behind the gate
[Music]
we didn't buy this house to one-up our
friends who didn't buy a house behind
the gate but we had a lot of friends
that really thought we did we had
friends that were like no we won't come
and visit we won't come and see you we
won't
kind of that you moved over there we
moved over here
it's really sad
[Music]
in general everyone pretty much keeps to
themselves
[Music]
we don't know anything about our
neighbors say nothing
I found another hamburger
one of the things that for a couple of
our neighbors has really bent them out
of shape is that we haven't hired a
gardener so this Neighbor comes out and
stares at me visibly pregnant raking
leaves is just staring
and he yells from across the street you
know only poor people only only poor
people write their own leaves
how excited are you to take that Jaguar
be nice how excited are you to see the
house I'm very excited
I think this community is going to be
like more young people that are like us
so it's like I'm going to meet a whole
new crew of young dads who are going to
want to play football and softball with
me and tennis and I feel like this is
the best community that we could ever
have wanted it has everything it has the
great School District I mean I think
we've really lucked out great with
Stephen talking to someone the other day
and he was like it's like a place where
there's tennis courts there's a pool
there's a guard gate there's like you
know there's a lot of young people and
he goes oh it must be Boulder Ridge and
Greg goes yeah that's it so it's like a
well-known it's like it's this is like a
diamond in the rough place this is like
the best place in Westchester that's
amazing yeah everyone bases where they
live around schools we're going to be
sending our girls to a school in Ardsley
one of the top school districts in the
nation and it's going to be a great
quality of life and a great environment
with great Future Families to meet and
and I think it's going to be funny
because I'll end up finding a lot of
Wall Street characters living there
hello golden Hi how are you good thank
you good to see you again good to see
you hello
I met in these gated communities people
who just say You Know Rich I just want
my kids to attend safe schools I just
want my property values to stay stable I
just want uh the beautiful amenities of
Life private Parks private bike paths
private lakes and so they're not so
aware of the way privilege works on
their behalf what are we gonna see first
okay so we're now in Boulder Ridge we're
in Boulder Ridge it's a large community
with hundreds of homes it has a
gatekeeper 24 hours a day so nobody can
enter here without it being known who
they are right that means that it's
Crime Free that's great I'm gonna make
me feel safe
when I go on my speeches out of town to
know that Sima and the girls are
protected exactly
nice cars here
I think this is the perfect place for
you
once you reach a certain tax bracket
there's this expectation that you will
just kind of keep up whatever the
appearance of the tax bracket is
cars are a big deal
most people drive a Mercedes or BMW or
if they do drive an American car it is
the newest possible version of whatever
we drive BMWs it's not that we have
decided to drive a 1988 Hyundai I'm very
happy with the fact that my car just
rolled 200 000 miles
it means I've taken care of something I
paid a lot of money for that's not what
you do here you buy something you use it
for like six weeks and then you get rid
of it and buy the newest version of
whatever the IT thing is
[Music]
people have always been kind of obsessed
with wanting things the car they drive
the clothes they wear
the same way you want to leave your
house looking good because people judge
you on what you look like or what you're
wearing
[Music]
in this industry when you're working
with high profile Executives athletes
and entertainers they expect a certain
presentation style so I have to keep up
of certain image in their eyes so that
they respect me and value my opinion so
you know I I definitely let my wife help
me sometimes with the
Styles brand names and stuff like that
but she seems to be very good
at getting me dressed for success
but I'm a big believer in that if you
dress well every day you actually feel
like
you're more powerful and you feel like
you're more successful and sometimes you
can like dress your way to success in
essence I've seen people get out of
depression just by just looking good
if you like the guy that's good at all
you become the guy that's good fake it
to you make it
okay
foreign
[Music]
mode of transportation when you're in
the neighborhood is a golf cart
everyone gets to kind of show off their
golf cart and they'll be golf carts with
off-road wheels and they'll be golf
carts with little kids and there will be
golf carts with kits that you plug on to
the front of it to make it look like a
Mercedes people will dump 10 20 000 into
a golf cart
most Americans are fair-minded and they
won't say I'm going to a gated community
to flee brown people most people don't
think like that they're simply saying
that
the perceived sense of safety the higher
property values that's why I'm moving to
these communities it has nothing to do
with race and so there's a divide and
that's how you segregate a community
those who aren't perceived to fit in are
not accepted people who did not golf
people who did not go to a certain
Church those types of people often felt
excluded
but we're not gonna go no hey hands
thank you
I appreciate this very good listening
when Max was little where we lived
before there was a park at the End of
the Street
the kids would all play together and
everyone had a good time together and
all of this
you know that's not the way it is here
okay up under the curb
okay
[Music]
there you go we at least ethnically look
like the vast majority of our
neighborhood and I still have not come
to terms with the fact that my kids are
perceived as the different ones
two near the swings
I don't need you to get kicked in the
head today
I have perfectly normal looking blonde
head blue eyed nice kids
and this girl ran in fear screaming
from Max
the playground just ran and she kept
screaming it at him how horrifying he
was and her mom was like yep it's okay
honey I know
something is wrong with this Dynamic
with my totally normal kid cannot make a
friend at the playground
[Music]
there has been more than one day that
I've called Ryan just in tears
can't take my kid to the park
[Music]
New York is booming with conspicuous
consumption very much back in fashion
the luxury car dealerships can hardly
remember a time like it do you believe
that an individual can earn too much
money what you mean that we should sort
of cap someone's income hmm
not really no why what's the point what
we know has happened is that people at
the top of the income ladder have gotten
all the income gains that have occurred
during the last 30 years people in the
middle of the income distribution
they've run down their savings they've
run up much more debt every conceivable
margin you can work just to hold your
place in the queue
you can borrow up to one thousand pounds
for up to 31 days it's the perfect way
to help manage your short-term cash flow
government figures released today show a
record number of people are insolvent
if you don't pay or contact us within
seven days our collections team may
arrange for an agent to contact you and
visit your home the latest date the
first
and it's the names today
within seven days
dress you go on the phone with them
November
oh yeah
my catalog bill is between three and a
half four thousand pounds but then I use
that for stuff that
you know when the kids need new coats
new shoes I've got no money left you've
got ah I've got to get it from somewhere
right I'll see you later bye say bye
everything's so much more expensive and
lucino she wants a computer and you feel
so you have to do those things for them
because their friends are getting them
and they're gonna look like the odd one
out if they don't get them
another cuddle too
you've got to cut back
School roles on the phone when I've
missed the dinner money payments that
happens quite a lot
then later
people went from pretty simple Financial
lives pre-1980 to the point now where
people are
just totally submerged in their
financial accounts and they're all in
debt debt to us might seem oh you know I
need this loan to go to school or need
this loan to buy a house but to Wall
Street it's just a product that they can
buy and sell in package and so it's just
another way for them to get as much
profit as they want and they treated as
such and they treat it like a game
hello
I'm at work right now can I call you
later but I did make the payment on the
third
all right five five four
thank you man
all right you have a blessed day bye-bye
all red dirt
that crazy
[Applause]
I owe a couple of deck companies now and
the only thing I can do is they gotta
wait in line I have to pay for two weeks
and then pay half of the rent and pay
the late fee on that and just juggle I
gladly pay you Tuesday for a
cheeseburger today
you know but that's the way it is man
hey
yo
moms or his house called him Joe who
said of his bills there's too much we
owe
we just need a loan that will last till
payday so they logged on to dollars
direct.ca dollars direct.ca is fast and
convenient just be 18 years or older
have regular employment and direct
deposit dollars direct.ca
apply and get cash the same day
one of the things that uh I'm going to
talk about a little bit today is how to
create a more secure America
by achieving the goal of five and a half
million new minority homeowners
they don't want there to be a fine print
preventing people from owning their home
once Wall Street figured out that they
could create these mortgage products
they were like wow this is the deal of
the century we need to make more of
these
this is always the big one
um it's the way that the economy is is
set up
you buy a house housing values tend to
go up and so it's a major component of
of your retirement so losing your house
you can find yourself in a position
where instead of being able to retire
you're just going to have to continue
working
when you go to buy a house you're really
making a bet with hundreds of thousands
of dollars that this place is going to
hold its value and that everything is
going to work out
houses that fall really drastically
behind the trend
um
I have a really hard time selling
and when they do sell they sell for Less
I think it would be more pressure if we
were actively looking to sell our house
today we just try to kind of keep up and
make sure that we don't
fall really far behind good afternoon hi
hi I'm Karen Hobart hi I'm Jen I'm the
owner of Rancho Miranda homes and land
real estate it's a pleasure glad you
made it this is listed at 429 900 and
it's on a 0.25 of an acre quarter acre
lot
and they have they've done so many
upgrades it's basically a brand new home
but it was originally built in 1981.
what I like about it watch your step is
they've done all the new laminate
flooring
they did not do the windows so we have
single pane windows dual pane windows
just in this room but they put an entire
new heating and air conditioning system
that was twelve thousand dollars now I
have to show you how fantastic these
cabinets are they're they're the full
extension cabinets oh yeah and the uh
self close
with the damper
hook up for a gas this one does have
propane it's copper lime
all the houses have a different
character in a different style
especially that one it's a nice looking
house and that one pretty the
Mediterranean yeah it's just got a nice
style to it
so this is absolutely one of the best
streets in Rancho Murieta it's
completely quiet you'll never really see
anybody going by but the people that
live here and the most expensive homes
in the neighborhood are down the street
yeah and on the lake
okay
well come on in let's see what you think
that first house has hands down has the
highest per square footage yeah I don't
feel like you're getting a lot for that
exactly by significant margins but I
feel like at least if you look in
comparison to where our home is at I
feel like we're fine if we did find
ourselves in a position where we needed
to list the house we are still we're
just fine yeah
more days than not my first patient will
probably be at 11 o'clock which means
that I would get up around eight get my
workout gear on and go for a run
I'd go running for about 45 minutes to
an hour
loving running outside
[Music]
I know I pushed myself but there's
really no option other than pushing
myself
you know your back's against the wall
when you have to make a mortgage payment
[Music]
he just had back surgery and he
literally worked the next day didn't
skip a beat had surgery Wednesday worked
Thursday Friday went into the office on
Monday he had a sick day he couldn't go
into the office and make money so it's
important obviously that he stays
healthy for himself for our family and
for his clients
the government had been collecting data
that showed had been these huge class
differences in life expectancy
and
people didn't really believe the data
even people working in important
positions in the Health Service didn't
know whether death rates were the
highest at the top or the bottom
from cooking me into capitalistic
principle which I put my smoke back on
his face but I couldn't get it so I say
okay for goodbye to all but one of my
principles and start conversing off the
floor that led me to the slippery Road
I wasn't always this way I guess it
started on the day they called the
Cottons on the casket and she flew away
and left me here grounded cuddling on
the truth pain my biggest ambition in
life try to get through a day
my mom thought he sucks when she died if
I keep drinking that's me
imagine that being dead at 36
sake
of all of the things that I need to do
to try to lengthen my life which is
already cut short because I was born in
Pollock if I make it to 70 I'll be lucky
and that's if I eat salad every day
now of course because of a growing body
of research people know that
unemployment and poverty have health
consequences
instead of the former idea that it was
businessman's stress that led to the
worst health problems
[Music]
a lot of health problems everything from
my blood pressure to AIDS to hepatitis
all different kind of diseases around
here
[Music]
any bug ground is a good day
that's what I've been told
actually this is what I know you know if
you can live to see it
my daughter's father passed on the 23rd
of last year
so
that kind of hurt me a little bit
back to being a single mother
he died of liver cancer
yeah it was really sad
it is it's a good thing
you know I know you're in a better place
he suffered
quite some time
yeah I do
we was together 14 years long time
in Glasgow
men living in the poorest part have a
life expectancy of 54.
in India three quarters of the
population live on two dollars a day or
less
no one in Glasgow lives on two dollars a
day or less and yet men in the poorest
part of Glasgow have life expectancy
that's eight years shorter than the
average in India
aha that's it that's going to explain it
being relatively disadvantaged
and found
which to
High rates of
violent deaths alcohol heart disease
so this is where I had my first
um
drink Outdoors
it was a Friday night we came down what
was it it was old a bottle of old
Westminster
and uh it's funny because like I ended
up developing a bit of a taste for a
certain brand of fortified wine
um
but I remember just thinking this is
disgusting why would anybody want to do
this
I wish I could become addicted to going
to the gym
you know like
and become addicted to fruit
oh my daddy different
you know like foreign
alcohol gave me what I thought was
confidence
so it's that core belief that you're
worth something that I am missing
there's a painkiller for your spirit
really
[Music]
everybody is trying to escape in their
own way used to trying to escape
um by doing different things like
marijuana and stuff like that um
middle-aged people probably drink or do
something
to escape older people probably just
don't care because they oh they don't
have to deal with that so
but everybody's trying to escape
something
I use my bed my cigarettes
beer every now and again and that's
about the size of it look at me a good
movie and go to bed
we're actually
I like ice cream
ice cream sometimes I'll sit with a pint
of that and eat until I can't eat no
more until I'm stuffed
I think you look good with a little meat
on your bones
yeah it means you're eating good at home
[Music]
I feel very anxious all the time
and the nervousness is just even the
customer say I don't smile anymore
for example a man yesterday he told me
he said you look like you need to calm
down and I'm like I can't you know it's
like you're gonna have a heart attack
and I'm like I know
[Music]
I used to work and I would leave and I
would uh go jogging at the gym and all
this kind of stuff and everything and I
got to where instead I would rather come
home and sit down and eat instead you
know
I was walking out and I was like man
it's been rough because we were so
short-handed I was like I'm gonna go
just go sit in my vehicle and eat some
chips till I come down you know
that's the wrong things to do
[Music]
if you take an economics course you're
taught that markets are based on
informed consumers making rational
judgments they're supposed to turn on
the television set
take a look at the ads I mean are they
trying to create informed consumers
making rational choices
the contrary they're trying to create
uninformed consumers that will act
irrationally and it's a huge industry
one of the biggest industries in the
country
[Applause]
the Texas Double Whopper he's like a man
man
foreign
people around here are uh kind of big
yeah healthy that's what I like to say
pleasantly plump
[Music]
s
me
oh I can't wait until Thanksgiving just
seeing that turkey
cause I got a hand man of turkey in
there
but if you've really fool don't worry
about it
are you tired
yes I am
I have to have my daughter I had
congestive heart failure
and actually literally died
and um it took me two weeks to come out
of the coma I'm just lucky that my heart
still is beating
long enough to do what they need to do
you know but that's just making it
weaker
blood pressure
um in 2004.
[Applause]
shut all the noise up
but they need to be shut everybody need
to be sitting down and being quiet
period
okay back to me
[Music]
it just makes me sleep easy at night
knowing if I'm home by myself with my
kids that there's somebody watching over
us
[Music]
next message
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I
always say I wish I had a husband that
worked a nine to five job you know where
we were able to come home together at
night and take care of the kids together
but I I know that's not reality and I
know he's providing a lifestyle for us
that without him working as hard we
couldn't have
we know that financial distress is one
of the main factors that sends people to
see marriage counselors in the areas
that saw the biggest increases in
inequality we saw the biggest increase
in divorce rates people in the middle
are trying to make ends meet and in the
process and experiencing an enormous
amount of additional stress in their
lives it's time for bed little calf
little calf what happened today
that made you laugh
[Music]
after a week I'm exhausted I work all
day and then I come home through two
kids to feed and bathe and read to and
kind of make up for all the hours that I
wasn't home during the day
I love you
night night
[Music]
that's awful I feel tremendous guilt
not being able to see the girls and put
them to bed and it's very frustrating
when the girls are more used to her than
me
hey
how are you I'm exhausted I should die
that's all right it was fun it was there
yeah
it was awesome
how are you I'm good
for all the criminals
in the neighborhood so
um page for page
and tell you who've been arrested and
what they done did and sometimes I'll be
looking in here for my son's little
friends because I don't want none of
them be having no fugitive while I'm I'm
in there cooking that's just from people
stressing out
because the economy is so jacked up over
here and that's why we end up with
situations like these people for
different felonies assaults and because
they mad and frustrated can't get a job
of breaking the animal and trying to get
in people's houses
pure
rage against another person wanting what
somebody else has
they'll just find anything to take the
frustration out on because they ain't
got too much else to do
psychologists and sociologists have
worked with violent criminals
consistently say that lack of respect is
the trigger for acts of violence and
aggression all that's left to people is
the maintenance of the self-respect and
so if that's threatened in some way then
you see these violent and aggressive
reactions
say two teenage boys and a 15 year old
girl
dinosaur gun fight at a birthday party
at a privately owned Club This Is Not
Unusual they've had a lot of people
killed in this little town in the past
few years high school students killing
each other you know and you know it's
you never know when you you know you're
going to be robbed and
I would love to walk to work or ride a
bike to work you know because it's only
like two miles down the road
but I'm too scared to ride a bike or
walk home at midnight I always worry
about walking out of that parking lot
always so with half the lights out right
now
you know it's a very dangerous place
homicides last year
three times the number of
police and Community are trying to
address an epidemic of violent crime
much of it rooted in drugs street
sweeper shotgun
12 12 gauge rounds in this drum magazine
no sights
because it's not designed to need any
sites
[Music]
I'm stressed out all this is just
it's just devastating look at it look at
me
thank you keep them around your neck
please
[Music]
I don't trust none no more
you know after the store closed after it
get dark around here I'm in I don't care
what's out there I'm I'm good
this war on crime is being waged at
every level
those who can afford it are getting out
of the way retreating the Gated world of
States from where they can watch the new
Republican battle for the survival of
America
[Music]
oh
Mr Hawk yes we're here to visit the
Grove Hogs
g-r-o-v-h-o-u-g
Steve booth there we go
you guys having a good night so far so
far had a good day all right thanks sir
oh you're welcome
apparently a neighbor saw it called us
Apparently one of his chickens got
mauled and another one got
nipped at and chased around
was able to was able to get it mediated
with him got him calmed down
the coyote side yeah the coyote siding
out did they give you any information
about that not much just that it was
crossing the road right up on the North
side did it sound like it was that big
one sounded like it was a big one yeah
okay so maybe he's been hanging around
for a few months now I think hasn't it I
believe so and then we'll uh the fast
lake pump house somebody tossed some
rocks through the windows up there oh
okay yeah that's a new one and there's
that uh other loose dog that we're
talking about okay
that'll square that away and it looks
like everything's noted on the cards
properly so
that sounds good I'll grab a cup of
coffee and let you stretch your
feet out a little bit and then we'll
continue that sounds like a plan just
made some fresh stuff for you
violent crime in the fear it provokes
are crippling our society
limiting personal freedom and fraying
the ties that bind us now Those who
commit repeated violent crimes should be
told when you commit a third violent
crime you will be put away and put away
for good three strikes and you are out
foreign
I get caught with a gram a dope 1.5
grams
okay then
I wouldn't hurt anybody but myself I
wasn't selling it you know I didn't give
it to kids or anything like that
and I go to court
that I wasn't trying to hear anything
they they're used at three strikes law
against me and they gave me a 25-year
sentence I've been in a box just a
little bit bigger than this for the last
17 years and to be locked up and treated
as I've been treated here
there's not a man alive that wouldn't
feel the same way that I do now they've
created a ball of Hayden mean
yeah I'm in the penitentiary
but you know something I've never
I've never been caught with anything
I got to get butt naked in front of
females and these officers and I gotta
bend over and show them my
yeah humiliating it it's beyond that
I had on I had all of my mouth
I had those kicked out on the Robertson
unit
I was beaten almost to death
they broke eight ribs they dislocated my
arms my legs they broke my jaw they
kicked out my grill they broke my ocular
bone my nose
but you know something the first time
that I did get my head ripped off three
days later it didn't hurt as bad
then I became a monster
I hate people
and do you know how sad that is to say
I you know I I've been treated so bad
back here that yes I could I could
actually now I could kill a man
you know I I really could I could kill
one of these laws and I and and then
that's sad that's sad because I you know
I was raised I was raised better than
that
and what am I going to do now miss round
when I get out what am I going to do get
me a job at McDonald's
I'll be 54 years old came down when I
was 26.
I was in college I was taking a votech
what am I what am I going to do now
because what you were before you come to
the penitentiary is not what you're
going to be when you were released
[Music]
this is a country that began with the
language of Liberty
and yet we have more people in prison
per capita than anybody in the world
[Music]
there's no doubt that
makes it much less likely that you'll be
incarcerated even if you've done
something terrible
Sonic Zelda and 2.2 carats of diamonds
this is the richest year ever in human
history the rich are getting richer it
is evidence on our list these are
creators they're not plutocrats these
are doers making things happen and when
they do well we all do well
there's a religion that says everyone
will benefit
there's almost nothing to do with the
real world so it completely fails in the
real world if houses the wrong word it's
not a failure for the
fraction of one percent of the
population that's accumulating wealth
you know beyond the dreams of avarice
the influence of money in politics has
risen dramatically in recent decades the
people at the top have more money what
they've been doing has been giving
bigger contributions to politicians and
in return asking for lower tax rates on
themselves and less stringent
regulations on their companies from
humble beginnings in small town Arkansas
to the world's leading retailer Walmart
has come a long way since 1962. no one
except for maybe Sam who never lost
sight of his original idea could have
predicted the company's remarkable
growth Walmart's an interesting case
because Walmart has produced a large
number of hereditary billionaires and
they are no doubt highly respected in
the communities in which they live and
no doubt they do respectable things they
fund museums and they give money to
hospitals and I'm sure they do all that
stuff
and yet you know in many communities
people who work at Walmart are
getting the wage but also getting food
stamps so that basically the public is
paying for all months labor
for a fiscal year ending 2012 Walmart
has gross sales of like 446 billion and
then the net sales were 16.7 but almost
17 billion dollars net profit I have no
problem when it coming making a profit
like I said I have my own business but
when you're making a profit at the
expense of the people who are doing the
work and their their own food stamps
it's a moral issue if you're making a
decision all right we're going to cut
hours so we can keep profit up you know
what you're doing
we've been finding that wealthier
individuals are more likely to perceive
the pursuit of self-interest as opposed
to Collective interest as being moral
and favorable we're even observing this
moralization of greed this greed is good
mentality this culture absolutely
selects for Psychopathic thinkers you
know people who literally have no
empathy whatsoever because once you have
successfully cleaved off ethical
considerations you're incredibly
efficient I think there's nothing wrong
with aspiring to be comfortable I don't
even know that there's anything wrong
with aspiring to be rich but the
aspiration of Wall Street is to have
you money and and you money is
the amount of money so vast that you
could pick up the phone or say you
to whoever you wanted without
repercussion
one of the necessary illusions
for the general public is that we live
in a capitalist economy but the rich
don't believe that for a minute they
insist on a powerful state to protect
them from Market discipline so if
Goldman Sachs makes a risky transaction
they're basically protected if it
crashes they can run to the nanny state
with their cap in hand and get bailed
out good morning this is a pivotal
moment for America's economy
problems that originated in the credit
markets
and first showed up in the area of
subprime mortgages
have spread throughout our financial
system it's been a dismal week on Wall
Street in the last
Four Points alone yesterday the Dow
closed down 500 investors agree that
this is a crucial week to see whether or
not the government can step in and heal
this economy I'm a strong believer in
free enterprise
under normal circumstances I believe
companies that make bad decisions should
be allowed to go out of business
but these are not normal circumstances
you know the president has said over and
over it's the people's money
he's right about that it is the people's
money but now it's the people's debt
this is a pain
that will stay with me for the rest of
my life but you get to keep 480 million
dollars
I have a very basic question for you is
this Fair
the spectacle of these Bankers who have
contributed hugely to bringing the
Western Economist to their knees and yet
it's still going on paying themselves
money beyond the dreams of avarice in
most people's eyes and they really think
they're worth it and sometimes I meet
them socially and they say Max when will
you understand this is how capitalism
works I say this is not how capitalism
works this is how capitalism goes
hopelessly disastrously wrong
foreign
[Music]
I'm the best person to speak on behalf
of the Wall Street Community because I
sit across from them
you know I see the humanity of people on
Wall Street are working harder now than
ever before
not knowing whether they could ever move
up the ladder and when will this Rat
Race end for them
[Music]
Dr Alden Cass is a clinical psychologist
and probably more than anything else
is known for helping people manage
uncertainty
and maintain optimal motivation and
performance
in times of uncertainty
Alton
all right thanks
[Applause]
it's become a mission for me to help
people out during this rough time
because I feel like in my practice as a
psychologist my clients are looking to
me for answers my dissertation was the
first study in the United States
conducted in the last 50 years it was
called the casualties of Wall Street an
assessment of the walking wounded and my
findings basically showed that we are
currently in a crisis of connectivity
[Music]
thank you
we should not bail out those who made
The Reckless decision to buy a home they
knew they could never afford
[Music]
that word came up a lot oh greedy
homeowners
this is just about four people who
bought TVs on their second mortgages and
it's their fault and they were greedy
that's the mentality blame the victim
[Music]
I kept using my credit cards to live and
then I finally got those where I was
maxed out and I'm at the end and
I'm fixing to be moving
I've got to go very soon within the next
few weeks you know I mean
um this this is this is it
you know
there's a lot of data
suggesting that social Mobility is an
all-time low people despite their hard
work aren't achieving the American dream
so who is it that achieves wealth it's
often those individuals that are born
into wealth in the first place
[Music]
I actually feel like I'm blessed with
having everything I need could not be
luckier
could not ask for anything more right
now
slimy
[Music]
dead 15 years old I left Big Stone Gap
Virginia and I hitchhiked across this
entire continent to Southern California
and I had a good time I was young
heterosexual
life was good
I was thinking about going to Hollywood
being the next Tom Cruise or somebody
you know I mean
but it didn't happen like that
my mom had heart and lung infection
and she died in 89 and it crushed me it
crushed me you know I went into a spiral
of doing wrongs
spiral doing things to get by and it
took me down a long rope that I didn't
want to travel but I did I was hanging
out with the wrong people doing the
wrong things
trying to make money trying to
you know survive pretty much I went to
jail for about a year and I came out and
still couldn't get it straight then I
had kids and and at that time I couldn't
have them with me because I was so
wiped out but after my congestive heart
failure I woke up
it was a wake-up call that I needed
it was a sorely needed wake up call and
I did that
so I've been Off to the Races ever since
[Music]
good
morning
we just don't feel that mainstream
school is a great place for kids who are
even slightly above the curve
so we'll probably homeschool but if
they're not staying on track meeting the
Milestones meeting the goals that they
need to meet it's going to impact
long term what their outcome looks like
no challenge is more urgent
no debate is more important
we can either settle for a country where
a shrinking number of people do really
well while a growing number of Americans
barely get by
or we can restore an economy where
everyone gets a fair shot and everyone
does their fair share and everyone plays
by the same set of rules
it's not the case that quality is
attributable
add apples but rather that the barrel is
bad the barrel is what's contaminating
the apples it's the institutions that
prioritize getting ahead above all else
that it's okay to break the law if that
means that you're going to make more
profits for the company with no
attention to what the consequences are
for the system as a whole
what I object to is the feeling that
there's some mechanism out there about
which you can do nothing at all that's
not simply not true humans want to
change this they can change it
[Music]
thank you
Jesus
[Music]
my name is Leah Taylor and I'm here
today to have a voice for my fellow
workers and everybody that's struggling
in the fast food industry Rochelle Monty
what would you like to say to the boss
of Allied Health for whom you work I
don't blame any one particular company
the truth is unless the government
actually acknowledged the importance of
the Home Care sector within this country
people are going to continue to be
filled these problems are deep rooted
within the system and it's the system
that needs to change my name is Janet
Sparks
and I am a Walmart associate at store
number 1102. when I think about the fact
that our CEO Mike Duke made over 20
million dollars last year more than one
thousand times the average Walmart
associate
with all due respect
I have to say I don't think that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish we'd never got into this state I
wish we'd never
had these extraordinarily High Rewards I
didn't realize that that was going to
happen maybe others always knew
perfectly well that this would be the
result of it but I think that that is
unfortunate and I I regret it I think
you know you sort of always have it
maybe in the back of your mind that you
know you're not part of something good
but I didn't have a clear sense of I am
doing something actively harmful and
then when the financial crisis hit I
started to feel really uncomfortable and
I asked my boss will the public ever
forgive us for this and meaning the
bailout and he basically said to me well
here's the thing the public always
forgets the public forgot after the
Savings and Loan crisis the public
forgot after long-term Capital
Management blew up
the public always forgets and the public
will forget again and we will you know
move on and it'll go back to normal so
don't worry about it
[Music]
foreign
for coming up for 11 months that's the
longest I've ever been away from a drink
and I've learned my margin for error is
very small
I mean if I pack up a drink I'm right
back to square one
[Music]
I can't do it all by myself
you got to help me baby
there's a push
to have a secondary gate to keep these
10 to 20 homes completely separate from
the rest of the homes that are already
completely separate
I think it's a status thing more than a
fear thing
there's already a guy at the gate half
of them with a gun
[Music]
and to be honest I'd rather live in
Florida
one of my next motivating factors is
going to be the fact that I do want to
eventually move to Florida and have a
second home there
[Music]
I won't have any regrets I might be
living under a bridge next week you know
but
at least I I tried
If I Could Be A Millionaire or anything
like that and buy one big house they got
about
50 bedrooms you know I have all my
family with me
you know I would love that I would love
that
[Music]
myself I always have enough to wake so
much
I wish I could see the kids a bit more
I could go out for dinner at night I
don't want much out of life I just wish
it was a bit easier
time
foreign
[Music]
most likely I'll end up back here
but it won't be because I'd walked into
a school and shot up a whole bunch of
children
or rape somebody or anything like that
it'll be because I probably got caught
stealing a loaf of bread and get a life
sentence for it
down
[Music]
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]